you know what the events in
Charlottesville this past weekend and
and the ongoing situation with North
Korea let's face it everyone's well been
a little tense today you know yeah
especially that North Korean stuff it's
really kind of scary
ya know our country is well it's
confronting a lot of racial hatred and
the threat of nuclear war and really
makes you think about how fleeting life
is how important it is to I don't just
make the most of it
Wow you are so right I mean there's a
lot of stuff that I haven't done yeah
things I've dreamed about but I've been
putting them off for years
oh my god I gotta go Hawaiian pizza
thank you boy
[Music]
is awful
[Applause]
do your worst Kim jong-un I'd lived a
full life wait a minute wait a minute
Andy we're talking about the end of the
world and all you wanted to do was get
some Hawaiian pizza yeah I just always
wanted to try it and see what all the
hype was about okay there isn't there
isn't anything else on your bucket list
like skydiving or traveling the world
and experiencing other cultures nothing
like that gosh you know what you're
right I'll be right back a slice of
Hawaiian pizza please thank you hmm nope
still awful Thanks
that's it kicked up all the stuff on the
list I'm ready to go all right let me
get this straight you just flew all the
way to Egypt to eat Hawaiian pizza again
yeah I just want to you know see if they
do it need different over there it is
still terrible bye come on do not like
it Annie
think hard there isn't anything else you
want to cross off your bucket list gosh
you know what you're right again there's
one more thing that I would promised
myself that I would do it before I die
I'll be right back again
[Music]
no stone unturned
wow we have so much in common all right
[Laughter]
you